what's up studio thomas here calling
from houston texas
it's time hold it done you know i've
been thinking recently
you know work is so stressful i work in
a warehouse and i pull products
and it might not sound stressful but
it's extremely stressful and i think
i think at the end of the day most days
i think
life would probably be easier if i was
just homeless but straight by
taking up cans or you know holding out a
little bucket
maybe something about the hair wrong
don't want to get your thoughts on that
you know very simple
the homeless way of living amen sir
and thank you sir and it's an important
question man
it's one we all ask ourselves every day
should i just be homeless
and the answer changes man
but the truth about homeless is look i
think about it a lot
i is it fun to be a contributing member
of society because that's the opposite
of homelessness
is it fun to be a contributing member of
society well let me look at this
um is it fun sometimes i would love to
lay in the park and do
dope and pretend i'm [ __ ] somebody
but i'm not
yeah and have a freaking you know and
have a two drink pepsi straight out the
two liter and get sunburned
yeah yes i would love that sometimes
but that's gonna fade off pretty quick
by about three in the afternoon you're
gonna want a place to wash up
and that's where it gets dicey
when the drugs wear off
you know when you start to know you know
you start to see different birds in the
park and you know
them that's
that's gotta be a tough moment you know
most of america's homeless are drug
addicted
or mentally ill
you don't need a lot of yeah i couldn't
pay my rent so i'm just
i'm gonna live out here now you don't
you don't meet a lot like that
you know yes sometimes i would like to
be home you don't think i want to
you know hide a cinnamon roll in the
woods
and go get it a month later when i'm
when i'm high on methamphetamines dude
and i'm low on mathematics and reading
yes i do but we need to be clear on who
is homeless and who is not
homeless people is either mentally ill
or drug addicted
and it's that those are the people
that's living under the interstate
you know those are those roadside
warriors
other people are camping
so many people send me uh pictures like
oh so many
homeless people up here in yosemite
[ __ ]
those are campers those are
campers you know homeless people ain't
uh free solo in el capitan papa
those are hikers okay
people are like oh man just just made my
way to
top of kilimanjaro a lot of vagrants up
here
r.i.p africa those aren't homeless
okay those those are patagonia
addicted carabiner junkies okay let's be
let's be clear those people aren't
shooting up heroin
and playing freeze tag with their own
soul
behind a carl's jr so that's what i'm
saying when it comes to homeless you got
to know the difference
kyd baby gang baby
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one